money can't buy happiness I'm sure
you've heard that a thousand times but I
want to tell you why it can't buy you
happiness but why people keep chasing
money because people are always going to
chase money and the reason people are
going to chase money is because it is
extraordinarily powerful but it can't
touch how you feel about yourself so I
think that people have been told lies
about money like we were talking about
earlier one of the lies that you've been
told is that money isn't powerful it's
not going to make you feel the way that
you want to feel and the truth is it
isn't going to make you feel better
about yourself but it is the great
facilitator and so if there's something
that you want to build money is going to
unlock that money can make you feel
amazing that you can do something
incredible with your time your
opportunity your knowledge you can build
something extraordinary that is this
economic engine that serves people I
think entrepreneurship is turning your
potential into skill set in a way that
allows you to build this ongoing
economic engine that allows you to
create something that improves people's
lives that to me is entrepreneurship and
that's awesome that feels amazing hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because in my first business I
was making 300 bucks a month I quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's learn
the seven life lessons that I wish I
learned earlier enjoy
so money's more powerful than people
think
but it doesn't make you happy what makes
you happy is striving to add value to
people's lives to improve every day
those are the things that are going to
make you happy so even if you're
pursuing trying to create a business and
that business fails and you end up not
only not making money you lose money
the failure will suck don't get me wrong
but when you're going all out every day
and you're improving and you're helping
people and you're bettering their lives
and you're sincerely pursuing getting
better so that you can serve people in a
way that feeds you and gives you more
energy than it takes that is the juice
the greatest thing that life has to
offer you is the following okay this I'm
telling you this from the position of
somebody who's made a lot of money
the greatest joy life has offered the
highest amplitude joy that life has to
offer is the following
you are working very hard you were
scaling a mountain and that mountain is
incredibly difficult I don't mean any
literal Mountain you're building a
business you're working to become a
great athlete whatever you are working
your ass off it is hard you were on this
Mountainside you have frostbite in your
fingers you can barely hold on but
you're going you can't believe it you
look down it is a terrifying drop if you
fall you die it's nerve-wracking man the
stakes are high but you decide you're
going to keep climbing you're going to
keep climbing and the moment where
you're working your ass off but you can
see the ledge you're about to get to it
it's all working everything that you've
been busting your ass it's actually
happening oh my God and if I get to that
top and I push myself up it's you know
it's it's success it's a buffet it's an
orgy it's whatever it's something
incredibly exciting that you have just
been so amped to get up there to
that is way more exciting than the
success the having of whatever it is
that's on your Mountaintop
it's that moment there where you're
clinging to your fingers you're clinging
to the side of the mountain with your
frostbitten fingers
and it looks like it's going to work
but it hasn't paid off yet but if it
does pay off
it will be extraordinary
that dream that moment it's all working
and if I pull this off my dreams come
true that's better than your dreams
coming true
why
because the way the human mind works
you can never eat a meal
so satisfying
that you're never going to be hungry
again
you can never drink a drink so thirst
quenching that you'll never be thirsty
again
you can never have sex so good that you
never want sex again it's just not the
way that it works we have this internal
hunger that nature has given us to make
sure that we keep going and we keep
getting fed and we keep
getting water and we keep procreating we
have to keep doing all this stuff so you
have from an evolutionary perspective
buried inside of you an insatiable drive
to keep going so you can't ever have
that thing even happiness is fleeting
you can't have happiness you can't hold
on to it it's never going to be yours
forever
it will come in and out of your life
but the things that create happiness
Improvement
sincere Pursuit
doing something you're passionate about
helping other people
those are the things that are going to
make you feel the way that you want to
feel lesson number two is stop living in
a state of Envy with Mel Robbins Envy is
one of the most toxic emotions that you
can feel and I know this better than
most because I used to be so envious of
people when I was younger I was I mean I
could find any reason to be envious and
envy is different than jealousy because
Envy is when you not only want what the
other person has but there's a part of
you that feels like they don't deserve
it that when you see a friend getting
ahead or making more money or they've
got a new handbag or they've got a
better car or a bigger house or they're
going on a fancy trip that you start to
feel this toxic emotion called Envy and
I'm telling you that if you're somebody
who struggles because you feel envious
of other people in your life you have
got to get a hold on this because it
will corrode you and the reason why Envy
is so toxic is because of the edge to it
I've made a lot of videos about the
power of jealousy not jealousy in a
relationship but jealousy of looking
around and seeing people that are out
there doing things that you're jealous
of and using jealousy as a signal to
pull you forward Envy corrodes you envy
makes you stuck and the reason why Envy
is so dangerous is because there's an
undercurrent to it that none of us talk
about and this is what it is
when you're envious of somebody else
deep in your heart you have a belief
that because that person got that
handbag or they got that promotion or
they got to go on that trip that somehow
their success their Good Fortune it's
robbing you of yours that there's only
so much happiness there's only so much
money so many trips in the world to go
around and if you see somebody that's
doing something that you want they just
took it away from you so this is why
Envy becomes so dangerous to you because
if you live your life believing there's
only so much in the world to go around
you are living your life
in conflict with the fundamental laws of
the way that the world works when you
think about abundance when you think
about possibility when you think about
dreams and success those are infinite
abundance means that it is there for the
taking for everybody that there's no
limit to the amount of happiness or
kitchen renovations or designer genes or
promotions that can go around and when
you allow yourself to live in a state
where you're envious of other people you
are living your life believing that
there's only so much happiness and
somebody else getting to be happy
somebody else getting to get engaged
somebody else getting to launch that
business somehow robs you of yours
because there's not enough to go around
you have got to change it
you have got a first and fundamentally
believe that there is Success happiness
money riches possibility for everybody
there's enough for everybody that
nobody's in competition with you and
that in fact when you see somebody that
has something that you desire you should
be happy you want to know why you should
be happy because it's a sign that it's
possible it's a sign that it's coming to
you it's a sign that you're on your way
if you allow Envy to creep in you have
now aligned your life with the belief
that there's not enough to go around you
need to stop that right now so bottom
line Envy knock it off it will never
help you get what you want in fact it's
going to keep you stuck and miserable so
do the work to catch yourself when
you're feeling envious and remind
yourself that if you want abundance in
your life you better start believing
that there's enough for everybody to go
around and you better start learning how
to be happy for other people lesson
number three is take action with Jay
Shetty on the subject of happiness you
know I think you would agree that we're
suffering from an epidemic of loneliness
and and you know depression and you know
people are seeking for answers and
different ways of living their their
sensing their lack of uh you know their
lack of contentment with the path that
they've chosen for themselves and you go
online
and somebody's telling you to you know
find your bliss or you know seek out
your passion and and I think that that's
although perhaps coming from a good
place is not necessarily helpful and
perhaps damaging because it leaves that
person thinking well I don't I don't
know what my passion is or you know I'm
not happy but I don't understand the
path forward to find that happiness and
and I I'm unsure about what steps I need
to take in order to gird my life with
more purpose and to try to find more
fulfillment so with the experiences that
you've had like how do you speak to that
person or meet them where they're at to
try to get them to reframe their
perspective on how they're living yeah
so I think first of all it has to be a
two-fold approach and what I mean by
that is there is an aspect of it that is
thinking and reflection and there is a
part of it that is action and
experimentation these are the two
aspects of anything in our life and the
biggest mistake we make is we do too
much action and experimenting without
reflection or we do too much reflection
without action and experimentation so
let's let's do let's break them down so
let's start with the thinking and
reflective approach this is a pro you
can do on your own this is the approach
you can do right now listening to this
this is approach that I half of it that
I lay out and think like a monk so the
first thing I ask people to reflect on
is is four areas the first area is
things that you
have an expertise in but have no passion
for make a list of three things that you
have a expertise in but no passion for
so for me I give the example of
Microsoft Excel in numbers I'm I'm okay
at it but I don't enjoy it like I don't
have a passion for it right so so write
down three things in there then the next
box that I want you to fill out is ask
yourself what do I have
no expertise in but I have a deep
passion for so for me it's Neuroscience
I I'm not an expert in Neuroscience I
couldn't perform brain surgery on anyone
and I couldn't scan anyone's brain but I
I'm super passionate about it I love
reading about it I love speaking to
neuroscientists it's something for me
social media used to be in that category
for me once upon a time social media was
something I wasn't an expert in or
didn't know much about but I was
passionate about learning how to
communicate
then the third box things that you're
not ex no expertise and no passion what
are those things in your life that
you're like Ugh don't like them not good
at them right maybe doing your taxes I
don't know whatever right like pretty
much everything everything else
everything else yeah and then the fourth
and final box is what are you passionate
about and what are you an expert in
that's the box that you're trying to
find so that box may be empty right now
this is the thinking of so do that
reflection exercise the reason why it's
so important is because most of us first
of all don't even know what our
expertise is and our passion is and when
I say passion I'm not just saying find
your passion I'm saying what do you like
doing what do you get joy from reading
about what even if you're watching a TV
show what is it about that TV show that
keeps you captivated well when you're
listening to this podcast what part
about it which person stands out to you
it's you having to weed in to every part
of your it's like start with something
as simple as what's your favorite
Cuisine most people go I don't know what
my favorite Cuisine is well think about
the last time you walked out of a meal
you were happy when you ordered it
you're happier you ate it and you're
happy the next morning that's probably
your favorite Cuisine try and find those
patterns in your life because all of us
have a karmic pattern in our life that
we've just not zoned into so I'll give
you another example let's let's look at
the pattern of the best decisions you've
made
if you looked at the best decisions you
made in the last decade and let's say
you pick three right three is a pattern
for me that's that's where I'm gonna I'm
making that up it's totally my choice
it's subjective but it's my opinion
three things are a pattern look at the
three decisions you made in your life
where you knew it was the best decision
when you made it not when you got the
best result but you knew it even before
the result happened that you made the
best decision I guarantee you if you
reflect on those three decisions in the
last decade you will find the same
parameters the same environment and the
same decision making uh thoughts and
thought process that got you to your
best decision so I'll give an example I
when I decided to become a monk I
believe that was my best decision when I
made it not because one day I'd be able
to write a book about it because I had
no idea where I'd even be here so I was
going against the grain no one agreed
with me
and most people thought it was the worst
idea when I left being a monk I was
going against the grain because most
amongst I joined would stayed as monks
no one agreed with me
and I was completely sold that I was
doing the right thing for me when I quit
my safe corporate job to do what I do
now I was going against the grain
because most my friends were happy with
their salaries I was I was doing
something that felt really right to me
and no one agreed with me and so I found
that that's generally the pattern of my
life my best decisions are those three
things now that may not be for you your
best decisions may be the opposite so
that reflection is really important
second half action
take the next month take the next 30
days and every weekend plan a new
activity Workshop seminar course book
podcast to listen to person to shadow
person to experience with take a
Saturday and Sunday and try it out
you've got eight things that you can now
test there are eight days eight weekends
in a month roughly test something new on
each of those go and actually do
something so this is no more thinking no
more reflecting if you want to be a chef
or you think you want to be a chef go
and do a cooking class see how natural
it was for you see how much fun you had
doing the process take eight different
things and try them out when you do both
of those together within 30 days you
could figure out what you genuinely are
passionate about as a starting point
that may change it may evolve but at
least you've got somewhere to start and
the biggest mistake is we're sitting
there doing a personality test trying to
figure out what our passion is obviously
you're not gonna know also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there lesson number four is fight for
success with Dean graziosi if you're a
little confused about money if you're a
little guilty to make money if you're
guilt a little bit guilty that you're
here that you want to make more money I
got to get that crap out of your system
because that is just a lie someone else
downloaded into you I want to tell you
when I was able to get money so it
wasn't the front and center worry of my
life guess who was left standing in the
mirror
just me
I didn't have to worry about the rent I
didn't have to worry about the car I
wanted I had to worry about my kids only
person standing I couldn't use that
excuse of I'll worry about this later
let me just slam a drink and keep moving
harder let me just do this or let me be
distracted when I was in my 20s I dated
obsessively I went out and partied a lot
like I always found a way to like hide
the crap that was living inside and most
of it was through work if some if I was
gonna say I was a holic of something I
was a workaholic for sure in my 20s and
then guess what happened by the time I
was 30 35
I started getting successful I started
paying paid off all my debts I retired
my parents I get in my 40s and I'm like
really successful and I don't have to
think about money anymore I don't have
to worry about it I worry about my
companies my family and all that stuff
and the only person left standing in the
mirror was me
what I'm telling you what success can do
it can allow you to spend the time on
the things you really need to do that
you're avoiding through work you're
avoiding through cocktails you're
avoiding through surfing on the internet
avoiding because you binge out on
Netflix avoiding through sex through any
anything there's things that we can put
out there to hide and mask
and when you get money out of the way
and you get to look at you in the mirror
you could say now it's time to be a
better version of me and if anybody
would have ever told me that in my 20s
I'd be like what the hell are you
talking about if I get money I don't
have to worry anymore
when I got money out of the way the
worry went up because I had nothing to
worry about anymore except looking in
the mirror and go this guy's pretty
screwed up like you made the money now
let's find a way to be a better human
and when I got to work on me I went from
being in my previous relationship a good
provider as a husband an amazing dad
that wasn't amazing I got to work on me
and now married to the love of my life
and I get to know what Real Love is Real
compassion real intimacy real connection
real friendship I get to be a dad that's
completely connected to my children in a
way that I thought I was or
but in a whole different world because I
got the coaching I spent the money I
spent the time I interviewed people who
are good parents and who have great
relationships I got to heal the child
that was I got to forgive my dad all the
way completely forgive my dad my heart
is complete there's no animosity
anywhere for my dad I won't die with any
regrets I don't I think of all the time
what regrets would I have how do I solve
them now right
and it gave me a freedom that I never
realized existed so if you want
something today to fight for
to fight for the person you're supposed
to be you're meant to be fight for that
fight for the healing that you could be
and then here's the cool part then like
when I got that and listen I also know
how many of you are successful on here
please I'm not talking to you like you
have nothing and I have that's not what
I'm saying but I want to tell you this
evolution is I got money out of the way
I started seeing success and then when I
started becoming a better version of me
I got in better relationships I was
better to my team I became a better
trainer I became a better human then all
of a sudden when I got my own money out
of the way I love that saying when
you're on an airplane and it says put
your oxygen mask on first right think
about that you put your oxygen mask on
first
and then what's the next thing you do
then you put it on other people once you
get your oxygen mask on then you could
say okay I'm safe I'm secure you get to
focus on the things that are really
important you see I watch my mom and dad
my whole childhood they didn't even
realize that now I'm older I didn't
realize that as a kid that money was
their number one thing I lived in a
trailer park with my mom we couldn't
even afford the rent we got evicted from
the trailer park we lived in and moved
in with my grandmother my mom worked
three jobs money was always the thing
she was a slave to it she didn't have a
degree my mother's most beautiful woman
on the planet had dyslexia really bad
and never really got that fixed so she
always considered herself not that smart
so she would never go for a real job
like something that filled her heart she
would go for cleaning houses and
painting houses and cleaning up uh
salons and cutting hair when she could
on the side and like she did all these
things and none of those are
disrespectful she worked right
but money was her thing she didn't have
time to work on her personal growth or
work on her emotional intelligence or
overcome the things that may have went a
little sideways as a kid and try to heal
that child that was scared she didn't my
father was the youngest at 12 was beat
physically really bad
to where that that's why he didn't stay
married long that's why he had 11
brothers and sisters and didn't talk to
any of them he was in a physical relate
physically abusive relationship and
never took the time to heal that or
forgive himself or forgive his father
right because all he worried about was
making the next dollar right I get that
maybe that's one of the reasons I'm
successful because I saw both my parents
struggle so much with that that it's
like I want to get that crap out of the
way like they never had time to work on
themselves right and I want to tell you
as a person who didn't come from
anything and legit went to school
without lunch money some days
that I always thought money
was gonna heal me I just thought I'll
get more successful get more rich and
I'll be good
kind of true but not really not in the
way I thought being successful allows
you to help flourish the economy of
course but it also gives you leverage to
help to donate to fix to serve
to bring people together to help make
effective change if you don't think
money solves problems
then first off I don't believe you've
ever given enough away
think about that one
if you don't think money solves problems
you haven't given enough enough away
when money is something that's on your
list of things to worry about
it should be we can't do anything
without money we can't just sit at home
and manifest everything to go great in
our life we love that but they'll come
throw you out of your house or your
apartment they'll take your TV they'll
take your car we got to pay the bills
right
when money isn't as much of a worry
you get to focus on the things that are
really important lesson number five is
experience everything with sad Guru can
you give us two tips that you think that
we could live through our big as an
example to others
see when we use the word Peak
naturally you want to go mountain
climbing
that means you want to do something
others cannot do
not necessary because
the peak is not in what you're doing
outside the peak is in the way you
experience it isn't it
somebody can do something very small
with very profound experience
somebody can be doing big things without
any sensitivity to what's happening
around them
so essentially
what you're looking for just look at
this as yourself as a life right now you
become so many social entities you may
be lost in that but actually you're
alive most people realize they're alive
only when they're threatened with death
till then there's something else
they become so many other things no no
no no matter what work you're doing here
you're just a piece of life isn't it
it is a fortune that certain things
happen through us which will impact many
other lives wonderful but still this is
a life only if this life functions in
its best possible way everything else
will happen
best possible way means what
is this very clear that uh you are not
taking your your own apartment when you
go I mean when you when you die and
leave you're not taking
they tell me you're creating very nice
apartments and you're not going to take
it right your own accommodations you
can't carry you know that
so obviously the only thing that is left
here is the profoundness of your
experience isn't it
how profound is your experience to make
our life profound somebody says if you
have education you can do this well
everybody went to the university I
didn't
somebody said if you have money you can
do it everybody ran after it
somebody said if you can get married
it'll happen everybody got married
somebody said if you have children then
it will happen everybody did that
somebody said this is not it you must
get power in the world so people ran
after that essentially what should
happen inside you're trying to cause
from outside
um
what should actually happen within you
you're trying to cause it from outside
yes it is possible sometimes it can be
stimulated from outside but
it has to happen within you all Human
Experience comes from within you is that
so
your joy and misery pain and pleasure
anything and anything Agony and ecstasy
can only happen from within you
the question is only your joy your peace
your love your ecstasy is it on push
start or is it on self-start I'm talking
about upgrading Technologies
there was a time in 1950s or 19 yeah
1950s if you bought a car
you needed two people to help you in the
morning because it's a push start
if you got one in early 60s it's a crank
start you need one person to help
today all our cars are self-start right
technological upgradation
things which are most vital to you the
profoundness of your experience
the pleasantness of your experience here
but right now it's all on push start if
you have to be happy how many people we
have to fix in this world
if you
if you have to be peaceful we have to
fix the entire world
so there is an endless amount of
conditions
for your experience to be in a certain
way
and in pursuit of human well-being we've
turned the world upside down we've
ripped the planet apart but still
we are not a we are not the most joyful
generation we are definitely the most
comfortable generation ever never before
another generation of people have
enjoyed these kind of conveniences and
Comforts as you and me are enjoying
right now isn't it so
never before but can we say with all
these Comforts we are the most joyful
generation
no not true I am not saying we are more
miserable but definitely we are not the
most joyful
are we peaceful no are we loving no
so our experience of life is still like
how the caveman's experience was same
anxiety that guy was worried where's my
food you are worried where is my next
apartment
endlessly you think it's different it's
not different it's rudimentary isn't it
hello the idea of organizing our
survival process the way we have
organized is we need not be concerned
about it isn't it so hello
you open the tap water comes don't think
it's small it's a small thing just
hundred years ago water means you had to
go to the river
with a pot on your head
so today all this convenience that we
did why because we don't have to concern
ourselves with daily survival everything
is organized now we believed if all
these things are organized we will sit
here please start well that's not
happened
it's not happened simply because we have
not taken charge of this so peak of
human life does not mean you climbed
Mount Everest
I have gone up Everest you know that
oh you didn't know
to the top yeah very top
Somebody went up there and took a
photograph with my picture in his hand
so I believe I've been there
more sensible too
because this guy who went there took a
picture with my picture in his hands
came down and said satguru of of 12
people that we started out only two of
us made it to the top and I took the
picture and I came down we were there
just about 40 seconds
right on the top because winds were
picking up speed we had to come down
only 40 seconds I looked around and I
couldn't see a thing
and I came down now I'm wondering why
did I do it
because you wanted to know the peak of
suffering
it's not a simple physical challenge
clamping Everest is not a simple
physical challenge I'm not saying you
should not climb all I'm saying is the
peak can only happen within you it will
not happen outside of you
so if the peak and the valley and the
very bottom can only happen within you
people can sit in a palace and be
depressed
like they're at the pit of their life
isn't it so
hello
so similarly if that is possible you can
sit on the street and be on the peak
lesson number six is shift your
perspective with ADD mylett today we're
going to talk about the echo of life or
the echoes in life and what I mean by
that is you know that when you hear an
echo you've said something but there's a
delayed response until you hear it
coming back at you then you experience
the result and that's how life Works see
today one of the reasons so many people
are confused about their lack of success
is because we live in a very immediate
gratification type Society meaning
people expect results to happen
instantaneously because we can get
access to information instantaneously we
can get on social media we can get music
we can get a movie we can get a Google
search we can get a book we can get
anything we want instantaneously but
what you can't get instantaneously is
success in life and we've been raised in
a generation now many of us even older
guys like me we're programmed to get
things right now
and this hurts us in life because we
don't realize the Echoes of Life see for
me for example when I'm having a
difficult time in my life in one area
another all I have to really do is look
back 60 to 90 days and it's the
behaviors I had 60 to 90 days ago that
are causing the results I get negatively
right now and so like for example when
I'm not really you know progressing in
my career or in my financial situation
if I look back 60 to 90 days prior I
stopped reading the books listening to
the audios doing the things that grow my
identity and I pay the price 60 to 90
days later in my body my body isn't
looking like I want it to if I look back
60 to 90 120 days that's when my diet
got weaker that's when my workouts
weren't quite as intense as they were
previously and I pay the price three to
four months later this is true in every
area of our life our lives are almost
like reading a newspaper today
but we're reading the headlines from 90
days ago
and so that's what confuses people they
see the external results of their life
but but if you did if you read the
newspaper from 90 to 120 days ago that's
where the news was made not today and so
in every area of your life you got to go
in right now you got to fuel the fire if
you've got your business going your
finances going your relationship going
your faith going where you want it to
you have to continue to do the
activities that got you here in the
first place because 90 days from now
you're going to read today's news that's
how it works if today's news is you stop
telling the person you're with you're
loving them if you stop dating them like
you did in the beginning you stop
treating them a particular way you're
going to pay the price for it in a 90 to
120 days if you're not eating the way
you want to
when you eat a piece of cake you don't
see the fat deposit the next day there's
a delay and so what happens is we do
these negative behaviors and because we
don't see an instant pain or an instant
consequence for it we don't think the
consequence is coming but the
consequences always come there's a
delayed consequence for everything we do
and so today you're getting the external
results of 90 days ago's headlines of
what you were doing and the mistake most
people make is they get things going in
their life they get their business going
and they stop the very things that got
them there because they believe today is
the headlines but you're going to read
it in 90 to 120 days you're going to pay
the price and so in every area pour the
flames on pour the fuel on do the things
that got you there but do more of it
because there's an echo for today's
Behavior
the reverse is also true and this is why
most people give up on their dreams
success the echo is longer in success
see the negative comes 90 to 120 days
but the benefit the gain the increase
the result of doing the right things is
often delayed by six months a year 18
months two years sometimes five years
and so what happens is most people make
these Investments they do all of the
work it's almost like a bank account
they make the deposit they make the
deposit they make the deposit and then
they quit before they get to make the
withdrawal because they don't see the
results and success remember this you're
making these deposits you're doing all
the right things it's not 90 days later
you get the result often sometimes it's
not 120. sometimes it's not six months
sometimes it's not a year sometimes it's
two years and most people can't wait to
make the withdrawal because they don't
see the immediate result or they they go
well wait a minute when I do things
wrong I pay the price in 90 days if I
eat poorly 90 days later my body doesn't
look good if I don't perform right in my
business my business goes down 90 to 120
days later if I don't read my personal
development or listen of the podcast I'm
supposed to my identity shrinks 90 to
120 days how come when I do the good
things the results don't come in 90 to
120 days sometimes they will but
oftentimes the delayed gratification the
delayed benefit is way off into the
future the people that win in life
accept both echoes I accept in my life I
know it's a law of the Universe I know
it's a life law that if I don't do the
right things 90 to 120 days I'm going to
pay the price and lesson number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is learn from mistakes with
David Meltzer one of the biggest
questions I get online is you know
what's my purpose
I'll tell you what your purpose is is to
learn as many lessons as you can
because that's all life's about is
lessons it's there's no great quandary
about your purpose your purpose is
simply to learn as many lessons as you
can and look the lessons will keep
coming right and we put conditions and
judgments on the lessons we put
qualifications on the lessons as good or
bad or you don't know they're just
lessons all lessons to me are Miracles
they're not mistakes
right you have a simple choice and you
know I learned this lesson oh it's a big
mistake was it it was a miracle and so
why do the same lessons keep coming
right this is the continuation of the
conscious subconscious and unconscious I
believe that the reasons the lessons
keep coming the same lessons keep coming
so you keep dating the same guy and you
tell yourself I'm not gonna date that
guy again and then you end up being the
exact same guy he just looks different
um it's because you haven't learned the
lesson so you can stop the cycle of the
same things happening simply in a
conscious level learning the lesson
putting that lesson to practice every
day into your neural Pathways and then
it'll deactivate the DNA and shift your
energy so those lessons won't be
attracted to you anymore though there
won't be in existence anymore because we
live here
right at this vibration in order to do
so you have to understand those lessons
two things about lessons lessons are
right besides being Miracles will keep
coming if they keep coming the same
lesson you got to change and learn from
it right that's the only
lesson that you've learned moreover
every lesson that you've learned in your
entire lifetime you're gonna forget at
one time or another
so don't beat yourself up about it
right we're we're so hard on ourselves
that we create resistant shortages voids
and obstacles that although we may be
rooting for everybody else we're not
rooting for ourselves so instead of
saying make it make it make it make it
we say make it make it make it miss it
right here right they can they can they
can I can't
I hear it all the time why why why then
why them why them why not me
you're just creating resistance boys and
swords it's really simple when you you
know that there's there's lessons
that we're doing and that I'm gonna
forget every single lesson that I've
learned here's the cool part about it
where do we get empowerment from that
simply that you have the capability to
remember every single lesson and other
lessons that you've never learned
anytime
everybody has that case of capability of
remembering the lesson
I know you all have big goals Big Dreams
big aspirations just like I do you've
got Ambitions to become an amazing
person to build your career to create
contribute to give to be an awesome
human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits set up
if you don't have routine and structure
set up in a way that will keep you on
track then you'll fall off and and
having new goals without new habits is
kind of like you know having a new car
without wheels you know the habits are
the wheels they're the things that make
you able to achieve the goals so you got
to have good habits but the challenge
for most people isn't that knowledge I
mean you know you need to have good
habits it's you can't keep the Habit
going right have you ever started it the
new year you're going to get healthier
and you start that habit of working out
on a more regular basis and then it goes
away or you say you know I'm going to be
more kind and more patient and more
awesome to my partner my lover and you
start being nice for two or three days
and then on the fourth day you're jerk
you know and you're like why what
happened I said I was gonna be nicer
it's that you didn't set up the most
important thing you needed to maintain a
habit so what's the biggest secret I've
learned in almost 20 years in this field
it's so simple but most people don't
have it it's called trigger moments
you have to set up trigger moments to
activate your habits what do I mean by
that well let's say you want to become a
better person you know you want to
become more kind more patient more
loving with people now you can just set
that intention or write that down in
your vision in your journal or set up on
a vision board that you look at once in
a while but in day-to-day life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you'd obviously
become better well that makes sense well
let's use that idea let's use that idea
by setting up alarms on our phones that
trigger us to do the very things we need
to do this can be so basic you're going
to laugh and then also tell you how I've
literally taught this to Fortune 50 CEOs
and they said it was the one thing that
changed their life the most dramatically
so let's start with with this let's I
have a goal in mind let's say you want
to become more present and calm
throughout the day again you could write
that down on a journal I'm going to be
more present and calm you can meditate
in the mornings like today don't be my
president and calm and you're gonna you
could you could start out with good
intentions but those fall apart without
a trigger moment set up throughout the
day to remind you that so what if you
did this what if you just set up on your
phone three alarms during the day with a
label that said
close your eyes
take 10 deep breaths in remind yourself
to be calm
so let's say you're going through your
day it's crazy right it's 10 a.m and
also Bing your phone goes off you look
down and it says close your eyes take 10
deep breaths and then again it happens
at two o'clock and again it happens at 6
pm and again it happens at 8pm what's
gonna happen you always look at your
phone don't you it's going to go
throughout the day you're going to
forget and the funniest thing is I've
had so many people do this worldwide
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of people I've taught to do
this hundreds of thousands and they tell
me all the time that changed everything
and you'll think once you set it up that
the next day you you'll you'll forget
about it no that alarm will go off you
forgot you set the dang alarm there it
goes off in your face you're like all
right I'm trying to be calmer and more
present close my eyes take 10 deep
breaths re-ground myself here we go
it you can't do it once a day you have
to have moments throughout the day that
trigger you to enact the new Behavior I
know this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm
so for example for me on the opposite
Spectrum I don't want to just be calmer
and more present I Want More Energy
throughout the day so here's what I do
one of my big trigger moments is every
time my butt hits a chair I don't care
if I'm on a plane or I was like where
we're shooting here I I wrote a lot of
my books here I wrote the motivation
Manifesto here I wrote The Charge here
and if I'm going to write my butt hits
the chair I grab my phone I open the
timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzing and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water drink it down I do some
stretches and I do some exercise just
really briefly or I'll go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just two to five
minutes then I'll sit back down I'll set
that 50 minute alarm and I'll work
and what that does is every 50 minutes
it triggers me to change how I'm
physically moving it changes my
attention so that throughout the day I'm
continually refreshed so I never have
that two three four o'clock time where
I'm like ah you know why because I've
triggered my day so that my energy is
maintained throughout the day makes
sense right at least could be as simple
as let's say you want to be healthier in
your life okay let's set up some trigger
moments for you in this way let's say
every time you drop off the kids on the
way back to the house you stop at the
grocery store and get some fresh produce
that's just a trigger it's like okay did
one thing drop kids off now tied to that
triggered from that action drop kids off
is go to health food store or let's say
you want to get healthier in the morning
one of the easiest ways to help people
maintain a better exercise program is
this
set a trigger you wake up in the morning
your first action is to drink water put
your exercise shoes on it might get
dressed if you were naked just saying so
you get dressed put your shoes on you go
downstairs or you go to the gym and
that's the trigger you woke up you do
these actions nothing interrupts those
actions that's the action and you have
to have those set up one of my other
favorite trigger moments to set up is
door frame triggers what do you remember
that when you walk into a new room
to have a psychological trigger go off
in your mind that you've associated with
that door frame so let me give you an
example if I walk into my house at night
after if I've been working all day and
I'm going to walk in I'm gonna see my
lady I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times that now when I walk through a
door my mind automatically triggers
those three words and I remember to be
those three words
so what words would you love to have
describe you as a person that you would
be happy if that was how people
described you what would those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life I teach Executives to do this as
well I have them have a door frame
trigger when they walk into their office
in the morning as soon as they walk
through that door frame they have boom
three words go through their mind about
how they want to be perceived as a
leader I have them set up another door
every time they walk into a meeting into
the conference room when they walk
through the doors of the conference room
they have another three words that
trigger off for them and it just reminds
them how to be so these aren't big crazy
things a lot of people think they have
to completely change their life what
would change your life completely is
setting up more trigger moments and
associations that when you see something
you do this that when this action is
taken then that happens that when you
have the opportunity to set up alarms on
your phone you set them up so that
you're interrupted in your everyday life
to remind yourself to stick to the
habits to stick to the intention you do
that enough on a continual basis you'll
find yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
the Dallas Uber driver oh so as somebody
who has gotten into countless Ubers and
some small percentage of them know who I
am and then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
um yeah the Uber driver in Dallas that's
in this book
um I get choked up when I think about
him uh an aha I choked up I get choked
up because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day you've got millions and millions of
people that are inspired by empowered by
impacted by your content there are
people out there that use your work as a
lifeline and it is humbling and what I
am
really present to in the work that I'm
putting out and the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back
and how much pain people feel
because most folks know what they dream
about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy arguing against what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
I hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment but it's not
going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going I got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go I don't know if I'm worth
it I don't know if right now is the
right time to do this I don't think I'm
good enough I failed so many times I
can't go through that door
and that's the problem I want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
I'm the same way and so this Uber driver
the story that you're talking about I
get into the car and we start driving
and I'm on the phone as we're driving
and I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this daytime talk show
that I launched which was a dream with
Sony Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life and so I'm talking to this
person about the talk show I hang up the
phone and this Uber driver comes alive
he's like oh my gosh I can't believe
you're in my cab and I'm like why and he
says because I I want to talk to you
about something I think you can help me
and I'm like great how can I help you
and he says I have a dream of being a
oscar-winning
actor and creating opportunities for
other black and Latino men to do the
same in acting and I'm like freaking
fantastic what the [ __ ] are you doing in
Dallas right yeah the guy's 25 and so I
I go you know the game is in New York
and L.A I mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in Dallas
but why are you not in La why are you
not in New York and he's like you're
right you're right you're right I need
to move to LA like why not
and he says I have 700 in my bank
account I'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car dude
drop me off and get driving what are you
waiting for and so we have this whole
conversation and I write about it in
this book where I am actively arguing
for his dream and he is actively arguing
against his dream
and what is so sad is throughout this
conversation Tom he's like you're right
700 could get me there you're right I am
only 25. you're right if I keep thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about what I want to be doing I'm not
only going to drive in circles my whole
life is going to spin in circles as I
think about what I want and I don't do
[ __ ] about it and then you are going to
find yourself not at 25 but at 45 or 65
and you're going to be so filled with
regret that you never put a put a bet on
yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book and
the point of the story is does he move
or not I don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves when
you're going on a long car trip you take
your car to the mechanic first right to
get things recalibrated realigned and
ready to go that's our second end how
we're going to recalibrate for our new
journey is to adjust our self-awareness
neuroscientist David Eagleman says that
as far as our brains are concerned as
adults we are more like our peers than
our childhood selves yeah when we think
about who we are we mostly base our
ideas on our younger self so tune up
your self-awareness you're going to go
on a data Gathering Expedition among
those who know you best Simon sinek the
author of start with Y has a great
exercise for this when people say I
don't know what I'm good at or I don't
really know what my unique abilities are
that's because it can be hard to get an
accurate picture of yourself from the
inside right there's a saying that you
can't read the label from inside the job
so you're going to ask people outside
your jar to help you out can you help me
you're going to ask three to five people
who know you well it may be personal
professional friends to describe for you
what makes you special ask them Simon
recommends why are you friends with me
why did you pick me as your partner or
what makes me stand out as an employee
what do you really like about me as your
parent now beware most people will
answer first with something general
you're smart you're funny you're a good
listener that
not deep enough anything else ask for
more for example lots of people are
funny why are you friends with me
instead of someone else who's funny or
lots of employees are dedicated can you
give me more detail like a specific
incident or example that really showed
you that tell me more then you'll start
getting the truly helpful data and
information such as I love the way you
use humor to make other people feel
welcome and comfortable or you have this
ability to take our discussions Deeper
by bringing in insights from lots of
other fields that's very nice of you to
say you start to see yourself through
others eyes and get an understanding of
what's working what your strengths are
that you can go deeper on and maximize
and What Makes You uniquely you here's
an awesome idea convene a feel-good
Roundtable in person or over Zoom with a
few good friends or family members or
even do this with co-workers where you
go around and tell each other some of
your greatest strengths in detail then
you're spreading the love and the joy
and the support as well and it doesn't
feel as awkward as just asking it for
yourself please don't make this awkward
for me okay so what else do we need to
start a journey strong we need some idea
of where we're going right a map that's
our third end you just learned about all
these great things you've got going for
you but no doubt you also have an area
of 2 or 12 that's me where you'd like to
grow so we're going to create a map of
how to get there and one way you can do
that is to pick a mentor someone who
embodies that quality tea or those
qualities you're looking to grow this
year one of my greatest mentors is
Martin Luther King Jr specifically the
way he inspired people for a meaningful
cause and connected people to his
powerful words maybe if you want to
become better at relating to others your
Mentor is Oprah Winfrey maybe if you
want to be more strategic and thoughtful
when it comes to business it's your
father or mother that was the case for
John Mackey the founder of Whole Foods
his father was his business Mentor for
years maybe if you want to cultivate
Innovation or persistence your Mentor is
someone like Sir James Dyson or Richard
Branson next figure out basic simple
ways to connect with your Mentor
regularly if it's not someone you can
connect with in real life you can read
their work watch their videos listen to
a podcast read about their lives tape an
inspiring fact about them or quote from
them above your desk or put it into your
wallet remember it's not that you want
to mimic your Mentor you want to be
yourself and combine those strands
developing with those great strengths
you already have in place but if you
look at some of the geography your
Mentor has traveled it can help provide
you with your own map for developing
those strengths being proud of yourself
comes from doing difficult things if you
want to have more self-love more
self-respect more self-confidence more
self-pride it comes from teaching
yourself that you do difficult things
when something's easy for you and you
win you don't feel great about yourself
right if you were going to use the
example if you're going to run a race
against three-year-olds great you could
win that race backwards and blindfold it
right probably so great hey you won
awesome other people might celebrate you
other people might give you a ribbon or
an award or some congratulations on
social media other people might think
that you're amazing but you are not
proud of yourself because it was too
easy
and if you teach yourself that you only
do the things that are easy you are not
going to love yourself or love your life
everything great that you want is on the
other side of doing difficult things
here's why it's so important is because
when when you get an idea and I think
you're a genius right I think you've got
what I call Michael Jordan level genius
at something I think you're a genius I
think you're I think you are the
greatest in the world that's something
you you're the greatest in the world
that's something and it's probably not
what your parents did or your your
grandparents did or the people in your
community or someone like you were
supposed to do right it's probably not
that it's something different you've got
great ideas
what ends up happening
you come with a great idea and then you
believe a story why you can't do it
maybe you're watching this video you
come up with an idea or maybe you come
up with a different idea this morning
and said I really want to do this
here's a great idea
and then your brain immediately starts
finding all the reasons why that's not
going to work
it's not going to work because you don't
have enough money because you're not
that kind of person because you didn't
go to school because you don't have the
connections because you live in a
different country because because
because because I mean you believe the
story why you can't do it and this is a
really destructive and negative pattern
that happens over and over and over
again and maybe that happens right away
maybe you get the idea and then right
away you start killing it or maybe you
get the idea and you you start thinking
great things but then tomorrow you wake
up and then you start the negative cycle
of why you can't do it or maybe you tell
your friends or your family and they
tell you all the reasons why you're not
gonna be able to do it it's super
destructive
to come up with an idea maybe the most
destructive thing that you can do for
your mindset for your self-love for
yourself uh pride is to teach yourself
that you get an idea and you don't do it
then you get an idea and you play scared
you get an idea and you play small
because you're always trying to get the
easy wins because you're always trying
to do the things that make sense as
opposed to understanding that your brain
operates by a place that currently
exists and keeps you practical safe and
scared and your heart can create
something brand new that's never been
done before but does it make logical
sense because it's never been done
before
right that's what you really want to do
and so taking on the difficult things
not letting that be a reason why you
don't take action
it's super super important because
everything you want is on the other side
of difficult things
your self-love your self-respect your
self-pride will come from taking on
difficult challenges and one of the
greatest things that you can ever do in
your life is Shifting your identity this
is what makes you proud this is an
identity game what do you believe about
yourself by yourself what do you look at
when you look in the mirror do you see
somebody who loves themselves who's
proud of themselves who's who's a
kick-ass person today or not for too
many people they're not and so you get
wrapped up in the self-esteem of likes
and comments on Instagram and YouTube
and Twitter and Facebook because you
don't love yourself and you're hoping
that somebody else giving you some love
will will permeate but it's a cheap
substitute
it's a cheap substitute because the
inside game the most important game is
you learning to be proud of yourself
without needing the external validation
so how does that come by doing difficult
things by taking the ideas that you have
and starting to implement them
especially when you don't know how it's
going to work out and you don't believe
that somebody like you could do it the
two ways that I do it are
one if I ever hear myself say scary
difficult to hard
right scary difficult to heart is not an
acceptable reason anymore I can't tell
you the number of times I I I'm coaching
entrepreneurs I've seen in the DMs like
I really want to do this but I'm scared
you've accepted the fact that you're
scared as being a good enough reason
that's the that's what we need to
destroy
that that mindset is the exact thing
that has to be exploded
I really want to do this but I'm afraid
right fear is not a good enough reason
not anymore not for you scary difficult
to hard if you say those words if you
see yourself typing out those words as a
reason for you not to take action you
have to start to trigger yourself I use
those as triggers I call them play
bigger triggers they're triggers that
make you play bigger right triggers that
force you to play a bigger game
scary difficult to hard when you see it
when you say it when you're thinking it
when you're writing it down
now it means you have to do it because
being afraid
is not a good enough reason for you not
to take action the second is what I call
the boom boom boom test which when's
your heart is beating really quickly you
get an idea you want to do something but
instantly your heart starts beating
quickly
it's the same thing you're still just
nervous you're still afraid you still
think it's too difficult you still think
it's it's scary the difference is
instead of verbalizing it or thinking it
you're feeling it in your body so some
people are much more vocal and you you
know think think a lot and some people
they're more physical and you feel it in
your body either way either the boom
boom boom test or you say scary
difficult or hard that means you have to
do it
it's the single greatest identity shift
that you can ever make for yourself
that when you come across something
that's difficult you're going to take
action on it
that you are tired of playing small
tired of thinking small even if you're
good at the thing
you don't want that life
that's a boring life if you only did the
things that you knew how to do that you
were good at you're basically living
your life photocopying one day after
another
you'll get bored of it you'll start to
hate your life you'll start to search
for more meaning but you've you've tied
your identity to the person who wins as
opposed to the person who tries really
hard right and it's a big shift because
if you woke up and you tried your best
every day
you're rewarding the effort not the
result if that's what you did by doing
difficult things if you tied your
self-esteem to doing difficult things
every day you're going to create amazing
things even though most days you're
going to fail
if you tied your self-esteem to just
winning all the time then you're always
going to play a small game because
you're only going to enter into the
races where you know you're going to win
therefore you play small for Life
photocopy every day and end up hating
your life
self-pride you want to be proud of
yourself that's the only game that
matters you want to be proud of yourself
you have to teach yourself the being
scared doing something difficult
the fact that you're afraid they're not
good enough reasons for your
procrastination not anymore I don't know
how many of you have read dostoevsky's
crime and punishment but I would highly
recommend that in crime and punishment
the protagonist commits the perfect
murder and he has his reasons for it and
many reasons because Dostoevsky didn't
mess around when he wanted to give
someone reasons he gave them reasons and
raskolnikov that main character had
reasons for murder and then he commits
his murder and he gets away with it
but things don't go well for skolnikov
because one of the things he finds out
is that the riskalnikov that you were
before you committed the murder
is not the same as the riskolnikov as
you are after you've committed the
murder and there's a dividing line there
that you don't
it's like the red pill I guess right
it's like it that's the Matrix correct
the red pill
and once there's certain actions once
you take them there's no going back
and so that's what crime and punishment
is about and riskolnikov tortures
himself to death well not literally but
metaphysically psychologically because
he cannot tolerate
breaking the great moral code
and so it's a great book it's truly a
great book and and it's also
extraordinarily like it's a it's a it's
a it's a murder mystery thriller as as
well as being a deep philosophical book
so if you're in the mood for you know a
murder mystery thriller that's also a
deep philosophical book then that's the
one for you human consciousness is that
faculty that confronts potential itself
I think there's good neurological
evidence for this by the way for those
of you who are scientifically minded
because
we build
circuits within us for habitual action
that we've practiced many times that
seem to run in a very deterministic
fashion and we are a strange combination
of deterministic and non-deterministic
as far as I can tell but what our
Consciousness seems to be for is to
encounter those things that we have not
yet encountered and those things that we
have not yet encountered seem to me to
be those things that have not yet been
brought into being and so you could say
that what our Consciousness is for is
for the encounter with potential you
know that our Consciousness is for the
it's not for the past it's not even for
the present
it's to transform the future into the
present and and really that that's what
our Consciousness does when you wake up
in the morning you have a new day ahead
of you and the day could take you in
very many directions and and the weeks
and the years all of that can take you
in very many directions and you have
some apprehension about what those
directions might be you have some
apprehension about what role your
choices might make in transforming that
potential into one form of actuality or
another I mean you certainly know that
there are Dreadful mistakes that you
might be very tempted to make that would
produce all manner of hell around you
and still be tempted to do it it seems
like it's sitting there right in front
of you as a possibility you also know
that you know you could haul yourself up
out of bed and attend to your duties and
do the sorts of things that you're
supposed to and said a few things right
that day and that week and that likely
things would at least not be worth and
they would probably be better and I I
believe that I do believe that I don't
understand how this can be the case I
don't understand how it is that
Consciousness Consciousness can function
in that way because I think to
understand that we would have to
understand what it means for the future
to be only potential rather than
actuality and who the hell understands
that I mean no one and then we'd have to
understand how it is that our conscious
choices and our conscious ethical
choices transform that potentiality into
actuality into reality into the present
and the past and we certainly
but we certainly act as if we believe
that that's what we do we upgrade
ourselves for example when we do a bad
job of it we're upset with our children
and those we love if we don't believe
that they're living up to their
potential we're guilty and ashamed when
we make choices that we feel are
inappropriate we understand to some
degree that the manner in which time
lays itself out has something to do with
the ethics of our choice and again I
would say that's a very deep idea I
think it's a I think it's I think it's
the most true idea I know it's very
emphasize that idea emphasized in
ancient religious stories such as those
that are outlined in Genesis or in
Genesis with its strange insistence that
you know God is that which
brings order out of chaos formless
potential generates the world out of
formless potential and that we're
somehow made in that image which which
seems to me to be the case and that the
proper way by the way to go about
acting in that image is to act in
relationship to the potential that
confronts you with truth and with
courage with careful articulation that's
the logos and that if you do that then
what you bring forth is is good you need
someone who you can trust like if you're
giving someone your money like or you're
trying to take someone's advice or
counsel you need to trust their
intentions all right and so it's not
just whether they have integrity it's
whether they have your best interest in
mind all right so I'm going to get to
how I solve for that in a second but if
that is the first character trait of you
need that you need of a council of
somebody of any kind of counsel really
whether it's investment law Etc the
second
um is efficacy or their skill set right
so let's think of both let's think of
just different scenarios here so let's
say you might trust your mom implicitly
but she doesn't have the skill of
knowing much about you know how to
structure insurance policies or trusts
or you know investments in Tech startups
right she might not have that skill but
you might trust her intention right for
you specifically on the reverse of that
you might see that there's this person
who's got lots of skill is prodigious in
this but it also means that they know
exactly how to screw you if they want to
right which is one of the double-sided
things of being really good at something
right you know all the details you know
how to write the agreement structure the
deals in order to make sure that you you
know get the best outcome right and so
the idea is to find someone who has both
your best interests at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
and so you're like well yeah maybe that
seems obvious for me just even boiling
it down to that was very helpful for me
because when I look and I look through
advisors look for people I want to get
counselor from I have to look at these
two things all right so here here's how
I test for the Integrity piece and
here's how you can kind of like you can
control for risk here right one is I
always try and interview as many
advisors as humanly possible all right
and I do that because I'm going to get
as much information from each of the
council during this process that will
give me perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about Julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks this 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your Macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well I guess this is it right I guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgment yet and so the first step in
this is that I interview as many as I
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where I reach out to my network
I make posts Etc to try and get as many
referrals as I can alright so that's
step one step two for the Integrity
piece is that I try and have a line
incentives now a lot of times there are
incentive systems that appear aligned
but not are not in reality so let me
give you an example so in the real
estate market if you're a realtor for
example you may think oh this realtor
has my best interest at heart right
because they have an incentive to sell
the house and so that is why they're
going to get compensated so they want to
sell it for as much as possible ah but
they aren't incentivized to sell it for
as much as possible they're incentivized
to sell it as fast as possible and get a
deal closed right and so think about
this for you selling a house for 500 000
that's worth 500 000 is a normal you
know that like that's normal that's the
market price right but for you to make
an extra let's say twenty five thousand
or fifty thousand dollars would be
really material that would be a huge
extra outcome for you you would probably
push a lot harder to get the extra 25 or
50 000 now let's say that um you could
probably sell it in a day at 450 000
because it's below the market value of
the house right now here's what's crazy
is that if a a selling realtor you know
like total it might be seven percent two
percent goes to the buyer and five
percent goes to the seller if five
percent is going to your realtor five
percent of five hundred thousand dollars
right is 25 Grand okay and so for them
the the fifty thousand dollar decrease
to drop you from 500 to 450 means that
they're going to give up twenty five
hundred dollars so they're gonna make
twenty two thousand five hundred so let
me ask you a question now in the reverse
if they sell for 525 they're going to
get 27 500 right and so it's a 5 000
swing off of a you know 25 000 nut for
them and one of them might take them
three months and one of them might take
them a day so what is their incentive
their incentive is to get the is to is
to make as much money as possible per
unit of time and so they're incentivized
to sell as fast as possible and so this
is one of those things where you have to
put your thinking cap on and say are our
incentives truly aligned and so when
we're looking at this when I say there's
two aspects that I look for Council or
somebody who's going to help me do
something financially legally Insurance
wise whatever it is so first is that
Integrity piece and are there incentives
aligned the incentives being aligned and
you could restructure that deal and say
hey you know what you're going to get
zero percent on anything below four
hundred thousand dollars I'll give you
three percent on anything between 400
and 450 and then from 450 and up I'll
give you 20 right or 15 or whatever
right and so now they're highly
incentivized to push and now your
incentives are aligned because each
increment for you is worth almost as
much it is to them and that is how you
would align incentives all right now how
do you test for the second thing which
is their skill set this one's hard all
right especially if you don't have the
perspective from which to make a
judgment which when I enter new things
when I'm trying to learn about trust and
I'm trying to learn about investment
things and different Vehicles I'm
learning about storage units more about
multi like you're like oh man there's so
much stuff and there's so much Nuance
that you have to have right and so the
first thing is I like to usually read
two to three books on the topic all
right and I read two to three books just
so I don't appear like an idiot
um and so I can at least understand what
they're saying and they're going to
respect you to they will it's kind of
like defense if you bring your if you
bring at least some level of knowledge
they don't feel like they're going to
take advantage of you so this is this is
the first thing that I do and this is
because I don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action I said in the
first hand which is try talk as to as
many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
Consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do is they won't do
this work right they won't take the time
to interview 20 people or 10 people when
in reality these one decisions the guy
who you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that that
buys X Y and Z right or you'd or you
have somebody who who manages your
portfolio whatever it is right that one
decision can be one of the most if not
the biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation than where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do I think this
person is Integris do I think this
person has my best interest at heart and
then two do they have the skill to
deliver on that promise because I don't
want my mom doing my my investments I
know she has my best at heart but she
has no idea what she's doing and then I
don't want somebody who absolutely knows
what they're doing and does not have my
best interest at heart right which
honestly unfortunately is a lot more of
the cases that that you'll come up with
and candidly you know a lot of times
they're literally incentivized against
you you know uh in the insurance
industry they're they're kind of
incentivized to rip you off it's it's
it's pretty terrible and there's a lot
of Industries like that mortgage brokers
are incentivized to rip you off and so
you really have to look at it from both
lenses and these types of decisions can
make the biggest impact on your net
worth and your financial future simply
based on who you decide to work with
foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to learn the seven
best lessons from billionaires check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe I'll
see you there that is amazing I've made
so many foolish mistakes I love count
honestly I know people I was trained to
be future as a teacher you want your
students better than you are